Farmers inducer this,
this loop,
I don't know,
old world breathing,
which is a,
they have a bore and the south,
so they do natural breeding,
uh,
Mo,
like 99% of the breeding pigs.
Uh,
for one,
it happens with a lot of animals.
Pigs,
uh,
specifically,
is done with,
with um,
uh,
frozen semen.
Uh,
it was basically artificial
insemination,
so they had these super bores,
you know,
I've,
which there's like,
uh,
something like 2000 super bores that
they take the semen from and that that
gets impregnated into the south,
uh,
um,
and in,
in the industrial level because,
um,
they don't,
they want the good genetics.
And there are certain boards that have
been bred to be great producers,
producers meaning,
uh,
their offspring grow quickly.
Uh,
they have good fat to meat ratio,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Whatever the industry is looking for it.
That's the other white meat,
you know,
that's what,
that's where your other white meat is
coming from,
from,
from frozen semen.
I've a very select few bores.
Uh,
and so the natural way of course to do
it is to get a born a salad together.
And Sal,
when she's in heat and,
and,
and have them,
um,
have them work that way.
But,
but that's a hard thing to do.
It's a frustrating job because you've
got to get the sow when she's in heat in
the bore revved up and it's got to work
and you know,
there's some complications there.
So,
uh,
that's sort of old world farming.
Does it produce better flavor?
Well,
uh,
I would argue that it does,
but it would be a tough argument because
there are other people who would say,
well,
why wouldn't you get the super boards?
That's what they're bred for.
And,
and it's a no brainer when you're
educational facility.
That's part of the reason we do it.
We're an education facility,
so we're there to show how it's done.
Uh,
but I would argue that the flavor is
better because you can control your,
your,
your future stock when you know your
bore.
Uh,
so you can choose your board,
you can choose your sow and you can
marry that together.
And you can,
through patients through time,
through generations,
increase the quality of your meat just
by getting to know your meat.
Uh,
and that's what we're there for.
And that's the exciting part about it.
When you buy off the Internet,
go to swine,
genetics.com you can get frozen semen
and you can,
uh,
you can use that,
but it,
but you really don't know what you're
getting and you don't know what your
introducing to your farm.
And so in this way,
you're in a closed system and it,
it seems to me to be a much more
interesting way.
And,
and,
and for me,
flavorful way
arm for the future.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
the other white meat basically there,
they've gone in the other direction.
You know,
they've tried to work out any fat,
uh,
because basically in the seventies
chicken,
the chicken industry exploded a,
and it will,
you know,
was lean white meat,
uh,
and it took away,
directly impacted,
uh,
the pork industry.
So the pork industry launched this
enormous effort in the eighties.
A bring back sales.
I did it by,
by with a slogan,
the other white meat.
And that was basically to breed out the
fat,
uh,
and to,
get the other lean white meat,
which was cheaper and,
and,
and supposedly delicious and so,
so,
and,
and more helpful for you and whatnot.
So we've lost a tremendous amount of,
of breeding knowledge of,
of,
of a stock of pigs that provide fat.
And when you,
when you have intermuscular fat and fat,
you have tons of flavor because the fat
carries the flavor.
Uh,
so what we're doing is breeding older
varieties of bigs that,
um,
that have a lot of flavor,
they grow slower,
uh,
and they're a little bit more difficult
to raise and you can't raise them in
this confinement factory facility.
So it's more expensive,
but it's much more delicious and it's
much better for the environment.
And there are studies that show that
it's much better for you.
So,
uh,
on all three.
But,
but you know,
the,
the trick,
it seems to me here with this,
with the stoma,
just looking at the overall gestalt of
this thing is like,
is that flavor is,
is the leader.
Um,
now if you had one of the farmers
sitting here,
he might argue and I think pretty
passionately that,
that,
well if you had the animal farm or he
probably argued passionately that it's
the humanity of the,
of the pig that thereafter.
So,
so that,
that the,
the best life for the pig is what his
goal is.
And the vegetable farmer probably say,
do I know in the vegetable farmer Jack,
you'd probably say something like,
you know,
it's the ecology,
it's about the environment.
You know,
it's about,
you want to,
to encourage all the floor on the fauna.
And it all relates,
it's one ecosystem and one mini
ecosystem and that's what you're after.
And food is important.
You know,
the,
the quality of the food is important in
there,
which are really great.
And,
and Craig with the humanities.
And so,
so me,
you know,
like,
uh,
my father always said like to a shoe
man,
uh,
you know,
there's nothing like leather,
right?
And so to me,
like to,
to,
to on this place,
like there's nothing like the best way
or food,
and I think,
I don't want to say I win in this,
but I think we all win because if you
lead with flavor,
if you lead with the flavor of the pork
or the carrot and you backtrack,
you're going to end up having to
practice the best ecological
stewardship.
You're going to have to have the best
biology in the soil,
uh,
the best nutrient density in the soil
because otherwise you don't get the
flavor for that pig.
You're going to have to do the best
breeding practices,
which are gonna lead to the best
ecological conditions for the pig and
the best humanity.
Uh,
so this idea that flavor and hedonism
and delicious food runs amok to
environmental stewardship and,
and,
and humane treatment of animals and even
economy,
even,
uh,
you know,
making money is,
it's a false choice.
It's the same thing.
And that's why,
you know,
I believe strongly that chefs,
chefs can lead this in the future
because our,
what our leather is good flavor.
It's hedonism.
And that's what we're talking about here
with all of this is,
is,
is hedonism.
And why the message,
it seems to me to be so strong for the
future,
why people are catching on because it's
not about,
it's not about sacrifice.
You know,
it's not about a religious kind of thing
where you have to give up something to,
to find a sense of fulfillment.
In fact,
it's the opposite.
It's you do more of the hedonistic,
pleasurable eating experience and you're
doing better.
Uh,
so if you're after the best flavor,
he just is axiomatic that,
that the best ecological practices,
environmental practices are going to be
in hand,
are not far behind.
And the most humane treatment of the
landscape and of the animals is not far
behind.
And also the best economy.
You know,
that it is a false assumption that that,
uh,
really flavorful food is expensive food.
It's not,
it's really not.
And,
and I,
we prove that it's stone barns every
day.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the cost of doing business and
agriculture is about distribution.
It is not about the actual adequate to
be actual growing.
If the farmers were the one getting rich
and our big food chain,
it'd be a whole different story.
If they're not,
they're struggling to get by.
It's the middlemen,
the men who are,
who are distributing to have the power
of distribution and the sellers in the
marketplace that make the money,
that value adds of the product or make
the money just in pure distribution and
economies of scale.
It's never about the,
the,
the number of,
of carrots that you can take out of the
ground per acre.
So,
so economy,
ecology,
flavor,
they're all one in the same.
And,
and it's,
I think that's a,
that's a powerful message for the future
because it's not about giving up
something,
it's about doing more of the same house.